it's not been so short-term on
everything just you know just following
my heart you gotta change as a person
you gotta gotta get better and I want to
grow I want to continue man you know who
inspired me man I was just inspired by
really both coasts we do this for the
people that's in line when we pull up to
the venues and if you was 20 in a day I
like to sit with it makes it you gotta
just put the right teams together now
when you could be on the whole nother
ballgame
man well feeling right now ain't even
about the numbers no more don't be
content don't be content here's an
American rapper and entrepreneur in 2009
he founded the record label Maybach
Music Group he was the first artist
signed to did his management company
he's Rick Ross and here are his top ten
rules for success you know I just felt
everybody situation is unique I feel
everybody situation is different you
know the most definitely you got a um
gotta think of tomorrow no not just
today so the decisions you make you
should most definitely consider you know
you know long term and I think that's
the difference you know let's not be so
short-term on everything now now now
let's kind of just cut it let's be
patient and on a lot of different things
I'm most definitely invested as one of
them how do you choose what businesses
you get involved in um you know really
just just you know just following my
heart really everything that I've really
done up at this point was something that
you know something I really um you know
something I really had love or passion
for yeah because if it's lifestyle I
feel like you know we're gonna win that
it you know that mean if it's you know
fashion if it's you know something to
deal with you know because you know we
give a lot of gang we lead us when they
come to that type of stuff you're not
just throwing your name attaching your
knees so much has happened between your
first album and now talk to me about how
do you have you change as a person like
your friends around you gotta change you
gotta change as a person you gotta gotta
get better you know times change you
know your position change your rank
change your power change your influence
change and all these things hopefully
you could use
in a positive way way you and your team
could benefit from you feel like being
financially smart is one of the reasons
why you'll basically be rich forever why
you're a hood billionaire so to speak I
most definitely think that's real
important none of me just saw you know
that just you know it all leads back to
your lifestyle you know longevity and
you know just taking advantage of the
situations and opportunities you have
and I feel just you know through the
passing you know it's so many different
eras and times we see people that was
just so successful
you know appeared successful and ended
up you know in different situations
almost definitely you know I want to
grow I want to continue to look cool
spide you coming up in the game man you
know who inspired me man I was just
inspired by really both coach I just
remember when the NW wave hit you know I
was still in elementary school man and
um you know I
you know the storytelling that ice cube
and you know the crew over there was
doing and then I think it was the
fashion and the style of the East Coast
when I start them from do key ropes and
I saw you know them 500s CLD zoo
convertible Mercedes and then converted
you out rocks of course these youngsters
don't know they else cuz I was a
youngster did it I was like yo man we
gotta get on our hustler you gotta turn
up you know when you make music you got
to please yourself you know that's the
only way you gonna continue to drive
yourself for doing this for so long and
if you don't agree or like what you know
the type of Records that's you know
being made you know saw the stores you
can walk in through the understand we do
this for the people that's in line when
we pull up to the venues we do this for
the for the fans that we love that was
standing in line last night that get
they self-made three CD covers made and
those are the people who we talking to
those are the ones when making music for
keep it real when I interview
to me in a day I like to sit with that
makes sense we understand and a lot of
times the games don't but the hustle
always do that why when you see me I've
got a quarter million piece on because I
used to manage sandwiches when we came
up and when we had time we play games
Nick is that love from swash down on the
roof [ __ ] you shoot two two threes I
don't know how to play with mirrors I
don't know how to ask and answer
frivolous questions but I respect you
being a hustler because you sitting here
but you gotta hustle I'm just telling
you then the boy ain't got a house in
the scheme of like everybody from like
the J and Kanye down to like a newcomer
and waiting where do you see yourself um
you know saying cuz you're the boss
right most definitely do you feel like
you've peaked do you feel like you're
there almost definitely not I mean it's
um it I mean I feel like the biggest
moves that's happening in our generation
of things that we just created in the
last few years I mean with from apps and
you know Instagram Twitter so on and so
forth these the biggest these these are
billion-dollar plays that's coming
together in two three years a short
period of time so you got to look at
things differently from when you
approach them maybe from tonight you
know you gotta just put the right teams
together now and you could be on the
whole nother ballgame and once you put
yourself in the position where you can
afford to to finance some of these ideas
and try some of these things um it's a
good chance if you but do you put
yourself up there with like as far as in
his fault they like puff and let's say
it's fine and as far as my peers you
know um I absorb game you know Jay Jay
brought me to New York in sign me to Def
Jam Records puff was one of the first
dues you know show me what a real bad or
money look like hit you know until my
life and so he showed you a bag oh yeah
the big homie that gave me a bag that's
G talk shout out to Puff Daddy bad boy
yeah you already know sir our boys
we're gonna do the do you aspire to to
be on their neck or do you think you're
on their neck already I'm I'm on the
back I'm in the back of their mind you
tell me a number where we at with with
the wind stops right now how many will
you stop this rig right-handed you know
I think right man the way I'm feeling
right now ain't even about the numbers
no more man it's just about you know
it's about the place we're executing you
know just us you know whatever it is we
got we just doing the best for what we
doing and you know we keep going and
that's what's happening you know that
mean so I'm happy to see you know the
team you know from the the managers the
team all the new you know the new people
that's bringing that new energy that's
what's making this boss wingspan grow
you know that feeling gotta be priceless
you got kids coming they want to take
these pictures with you see you in
person what's this all like four users
overall I think I'd end of the day man I
think you know I also feel good you're
showing them that other side of fast
money or music money
it's called investing in what you love
and I'm saying something that I love so
you know this will be invested in and we
build it you know around the family and
a lot of times that's what dudes do they
get the money bag and then go build it
with everybody but their family you know
it take time but I think that's how
you're supposed to do that when can you
consider it's enough hustle all right I
don't know that a hustler who's never
enough pushes never get enough but when
you wants it then say I I'm done
I'm cool I'm content with where I'm at
I'm an adult it don't be content don't
be content you understand you can never
be content these places you ain't
content and they built the be content
this is difference moving rich and
you're supposed to reach you're reaching
no way posted the bridge rates in our
Morning Post be rich I like my money
physically imbalance not like the back
say like much like a see I like the way
money every eighty pounds better no it
didn't just know that you feel you'll
never retire you
you'll never get time thank you so much
for watching I made this video because a
zag Allah I really hope I pronounced
that somewhat closely to the actual
pronunciation asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave your comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know which of Rick Ross's top ten
rules meant the most to you at the
biggest impact leave it in the comments
I'll join the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon